what's the deal with airplane
peanuts just stop can I talk this a
50/50 podcast and I feel like you're you
think that you're the captain of the
ship I am what do we we rehearsed it oh
yeah thanks for being a listening thank
you
thanks thank you for being a bad friend
which started three short years ago as a
side project with a friend to help Bobby
Lee get through one of the darkest times
in his entire life has since blossomed
into a top five platform in all of
comedy and Bobby's main creative Focus
but the journey to bad friends hitting
over 1 million subscribers is not as
simple as people may think in reality
it's a story that involves death
betrayal and a global pandemic to top it
off this is the real story of how bad
friends took over podcasting we really
truly made that because that show was
birthed from his relapse when his dad
died and he relapsed he pulled me aside
in the hallway at his old condo and I
knew something was wrong and he was like
told then he told me that he was high
and I knew I knew something was weird
and he was like if you tell anybody I
we'll never talk again and so
immediately I went home and I panicked
told everybody yeah what am I going to
do I was like I have to start telling
people I can't I can't hide this this is
nuts but I didn't tell Kila and at the
time they were together she had reached
out to me far after the fact that this
all went away and was like I'm really
sorry he put you in that predicament I
understand why you didn't come to me
because it was like what am I going to
get in the middle of their relationship
like it was it was really a vulnerable
position for me to be in so I made it my
own way to get him to try to get help
without having to bring it to the
relationship part because it was really
hard man Bobby Lee's father Robert
passed away in August of 2019 after a
long battle with Parkinson's Disease an
event that caused Bobby so much pain and
sorrow that he ended up relapsing after
17 years of sobriety and I knew when his
dad died he was avoiding the idea that
his dad was dead it was like it's like
he didn't care and I was like this is
fake you care so you're dealing with it
in a way that you don't want to
communicate and obviously it was using
behind everybody's back so once that
came to the surface I knew everything
was going to kind of collapse so he went
away to rehab and then when we went to
Mexico where I saw you guys he relapsed
again while Bobby Lee was away at rehab
Andrew Santino helped keep tiger Belly
Up and Running by filling in as a guest
host Bobby was allowed the necessary
time to cope with the death of his
father and regain control of his
addiction issues that Newfound control
also led to a profound realization that
would change the comedy landscape
forever moving forward me and Kila would
do tiger belly together MH and then and
we had joked about doing the show and
then when he relapsed he pulled me aside
when kalila called him out and they sent
him away to rehab and he's like I had a
realization that we should become closer
instead of this Fringe thing that we're
doing and actually do the show together
and commit it was clear to viewers
before the show even officially started
that these two had unreal chemistry
together Andrew had been a guest on
tiger belly four separate times leading
up to 2020 and Bobby was the first ever
guest on Andrew's podcast whiskey Ginger
it didn't take long for bad friends to
start making serious Noise online as
their first viral moment came almost
instantly in a very full circle moment
when you think about how this podcast
got started in the first place I wrote a
song for my dad okay let's hear it all
right Daddy I love
you Daddy why you
die Happy Father's Day
Daddy Daddy I Can
Fly
Daddy I miss
you why are you dead why did you die
Daddy I need you I need you so badly
laying in your bed laying in your bed
I'm sorry I took photos of you while you
were dead and sent it to the Hudson what
was in my head you were dead head and I
whipped out my
iPhone I can't believe I did that [__]
I'm all alone you Daddy I love you okay
there we go that's a song very good
nowadays it's almost impossible to
Fathom that bad friends could have been
anything other than the brilliant Duo of
Bobby Lee and Andrew Santino but
strangely enough Andrew was not supposed
to be the co-host of bad friends in fact
the show was never supposed to be named
bad friends in the first place at the
time time though right you I had
promised you cuz remember you and I went
to ATC I know brother we drove to ATC
before Andrew was even in the mix we met
with Al magal can I tell you something
this is the only reason why I was upset
that was it it was because you weren't
upfront with me we already went over
this but I'm just saying all these
things I keep hearing about this is like
I am not I you guys are still my friends
you think I don't I'm mad at you or
something like that no I don't care um
like I don't really care Bobby Lee and
Eric Griffin are hilarious together and
would have made a decent show but I
think we can all agree this podcast
would never have hit a million Subs so
fast if not for the red rocket the
slight betrayal of Eric Griffin in
exchange for Andrew Santino might have
been the best business decision that
Bobby Lee has ever made and if you
disagree just take a look at the numbers
whiskey Ginger compared to Tiger belly
in performance t or bad friends you mean
oh yes rightor bad friends yeah yeah oh
bad friends is huge D we do a million
downloads a week we're hu that one's way
bigger my show is my show is like 400
Grand or something like that it's half
of it bad friends is significantly
larger than both Andrew and Bobby's
original channels and podcasts whiskey
Ginger's channel was started in 2006 and
is currently closing in on 400,000 subs
and tiger belly which has been thought
of for years as one of the largest
comedy podcasts on the Internet is
sitting at 839 th000 Subs after joining
YouTube back in 2015 and the tiger belly
channel has 210 million Channel Channel
views bad friends has not only surpassed
both these channels in subscriber count
but also has the same amount of Channel
views as tiger belly despite being
conceived a full 5 years later that
basically means all the work that Bobby
and his team have put into building
tiger belly over the past 8 years has
not only been replicated but easily
surpassed by bad friends in just
onethird of the time bad friends isn't
even close to being done growing in fact
the number show they're honestly just
getting started which is insane once you
realize already the fourth largest
comedy podcast on YouTube with 1.02
million Subs only behind flagrant who
has 1.48 million subs and started in
2019 ymh at 1.78 million Subs which
started in 2011 and this past weekend
with theovon who has 2.07 million subs
and started all the way back in 2006
yeah dude when we're humming on that
show I genuinely mean it from the bottom
of my heart I've never had more fun
making comedy it reminds me of when I
was 22 and I started and we would talk
[__] after bombing at open mics and we'd
all be in the parking lot making fun of
each other for how bad we bombed it it's
the same thing it it felt the same way
it was like innocent and raw and stupid
it was so dumb it's when me and that kid
are talking [__] it's so dumb it's the
dumbest thing on earth it's great real
quick today's video is brought to you by
Underdog fantasy the easiest and best
way to play fantasy sports with football
season ramping up now is your chance to
get in on the action with Underdog
fantasy pick them games all you do is
pick high or low on a player stats
depending on how you think they're going
to do and you could win up to 20 times
your money in a single night if you're
correct pick between two to five player
stats and you could win some serious
money I have my picks right here I'm
taking lower on Russell Wilson passing
yards and higher on Michael Pitman and
DeAndre Hopkins receiving if I get all
three picks right I 6X my money Underdog
is available in 30 plus States and
Canada including California Texas and
Florida sign up with code joke world
today an underdog will double your first
deposit up to $500 they're also giving
our subscribers a special offer for Joe
burrow over half a yard available only
to new users with promo code joke world
now back to the video another key to the
success of bad friends is the autonomy
of the show to not rely on big guest
appearances for successful episodes bad
friends is completely self-sustainable
all they need is Andrew Bobby and their
team of producers hiding in the window
this combination alone can easily put up
million view episodes every single week
without the headache of booking guests
and forcing interview conversation which
is such a rare feat that even the top
two podcasts in this field can't pull
this off it's been really fun as a
viewer to see the rise of bad friends
over the last 3 years in 182 episodes at
this point the boys have done it all
from a world tour sold out live shows a
very successful merch line and the
development of multiple new characters
like Rudy Jules and jety Johnson to help
them out along the way guest spots from
last week The Joe Rogan Experience had
on Sam Alman and Jimmy Carr two bears
one Cape was Tom and Lane Norton kill
Tony this week had on Kim cogden and
Jamar neighbors ymh talked with Tom's
mother Charro we might be drunk C on
Nick Offerman mat Shane secret podcast
was Shane Mark and arri aru garbage had
on Dan cumins Andre Jinn was on the
Honeydew taste buds had a french fry
tournament LS black was the guest on
Whiskey Ginger flagrant had on Dylan
danis and hey babe had on Robert iser
and Tampa Tony yeah Money Changes people
right exactly dude what are you talking
about damp Pon just I got the sweatshirt
for free shout out busting with the
boys if this was if this was like 3
years ago I would have been scheduled
properly but now he's a big shot at to
I just [__] you know what I
mean I don't guys K because I'm here in
New York do you need to ride to the
airport tomorrow by the way cuz Rob was
going that
way this past weekend with Theo Von had
on sexy red the Tim Dylan show talked
with areu garbage boys Kippy and H Foley
who were also on tiger belly last week
the bloxs podcast had on Dan Soder
Chrissy chaos welcome Greg Gutfeld to
the show first date featur Jared freed
Rick lman had Todd Barry on take your
shoes off being in with Jordan welcomed
Rich Voss sok cono visited sav's world
and David coacher was the guest on the
Harland Highway as far as new standup
specials are either out right now or
coming out soon country Wayne's debut
Netflix special a woman's prayer came
out last week ased Blake wexler's new
hour titled daddy longlegs which you can
find on the 800lb gorilla YouTube
channel right now and someone told me
the other day that uh I told them that
there was afraid of daddy longleg
spiders and she goes oh well actually a
daddy longleg spider is harmless to
Human beings because its fangs are not
strong enough to pierce human
skin and to that I said oh do not
[__] talk to me like
that don't speak to me that way it's
fangs are not strong enough like
socialize yourself go outside what are
we
doing take that Fang talk with you I
don't like that I don't like it at all
and if if you get nothing out of my set
tonight this is very important she was
wrong she was very wrong a daddy long
legs is not harmless to human beings
because no animal is harmless to humans
if he makes you call him
[Laughter]
Daddy ah yeah look at Daddy's long legs
oh
God there's also a few specials that
will be coming out relatively soon
Heather McMahon son I never had is set
to premiere on Netflix October 17th and
Dan Soder will be recording his next
hour at The Helium Comedy Club in
Portland November 15th and 16th we're
definitely looking forward to Dan's new
special as well as Matt R's upcoming
special natural selection and debut
specials from both Kim cogden and selano
coming in early 2024 be sure to
subscribe to joke world right now to
stay up to date with both those releases
and not a standup special but October
20th is the premier date for old dads a
film that explores the ups and downs of
three best friends who become fathers
later in life directed by Bill Burr and
written by Bill Burr with the help of
Ben tishler also if you're interested in
hearing about what happened last weekend
at the biggest Comedy Festival of the
year which featured over 90 different
comedians we just uploaded our full
skankfest recap video that you can find
on the end screen right after this
thanks for
watching at joke
world
world and it world is wld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out